Tradutor: Raissa Mendes
Revisor: Maricene Crus
A educação é o único caminho
pra que o Brasil se torne
o país que queremos.
Quando a gente analisa 76 países,
o Brasil ocupa o 60.º lugar
no ranking mundial de educação.
Comparando 61 países,
nós estamos em 56.º lugar
em competitividade.
Quando a gente olha para os alunos
brasileiros de escolas públicas,
apenas 23% desses alunos têm a competência
de que precisamos
em leitura e interpretação de texto.
Esse número é de apenas
11% na resolução de problemas.
O Movimento Mapa Educação é uma iniciativa
de jovens brasileiros que se uniram
com o objetivo de aproximar
a sociedade civil do debate educacional,
pra que a gente possa, juntos,
lutar por uma educação
de qualidade no nosso país.
A trajetória do Mapa
é muito próxima da minha trajetória.
Eu venho de uma família humilde.
Meu pai não chegou a terminar
o ensino fundamental.
A minha mãe só terminou
o ensino médio há poucos anos.
No entanto, eles se esforçaram muito
pra que eu e meu irmão pudéssemos estudar
e dar o melhor de nós nos estudos.
Por muito tempo, eu queria
trabalhar com artesanatos.
Até a quinta e a sexta série,
eu estudei em escolas públicas,
e bordava e pintava
pra ajudar a minha família em casa.
No entanto, na quinta série,
participei da primeira
Olimpíada Brasileira de Matemática
das Escolas Públicas, a OBMEP.
A OBMEP foi a primeira grande oportunidade
que eu tive na minha vida
de realmente ver
que políticas públicas simples
poderiam ter um impacto enorme
na vida de milhões de pessoas.
Ao ser premiada na quinta série
e na sexta série,
na primeira e na segunda OBMEP,
recebi uma bolsa de estudos em uma escola
privada incrível de São Paulo.
Eu moro na periferia da Zona Sul;
a escola fica no Centro.
E foi aí que eu percebi como o nosso país
é marcado por enormes desigualdades.
Dois mundos completamente
diferentes estavam ali,
uma hora e vinte de distância
de ônibus e metrô.
Chegando no colégio, fiquei maravilhada:
era tudo muito diferente.
E estudei bastante,
consegui me destacar na minha sala,
mas, chegando no final do ano,
fui convidada pra uma cerimônia
pra todos os alunos do colégio
que tinham feito olimpíadas
e sido premiados.
Eu não tinha feito nenhuma olimpíada,
mas fui convidada assim mesmo.
Chegando lá, eles tinham
uma camiseta, bem simples e preta,
que davam pra todos os alunos
que tinham sido premiados.
Eu não ganhei a camiseta,
e fiquei muito triste.
Por mais que pareça bobeira,
eu comecei a pensar:
"Tudo bem, tive uma oportunidade incrível
que todos os meus amigos
que ficaram na escola pública não tiveram;
cheguei aqui e estudei,
mas o que eu fiz de especial?
Eu não fiz nada além; eu fiquei
naquela mesmice das aulas,
e não fiz tudo o que estava
ao meu alcance".
Como sou de chorar, chorei bastante.
E meu pai, que estava comigo na cerimônia,
vendo aquilo, começou a conversar comigo.
E foi então que eu prometi:
"Pai, no ano seguinte
vou ganhar a camiseta".
Sei que parece bobo,
mas isso realmente me incentivou.
E não foi a única promessa
que eu fiz no dia.
Durante essa mesma cerimônia,
foi uma moça do MIT,
e ela falou pra gente:
"Alunos brasileiros podem estudar
em escolas incríveis americanas".
E ela mostrou um vídeo superbacana
que tinha um clube de chocolate,
tinha um clube de salsa no MIT...
Eu não falava inglês; não entendi nada,
mas fiquei com os olhos brilhando.
E falei pro meu pai:
"Quer saber? Vou estudar
numa universidade americana um dia".
Não sei quem era mais doido:
eu, que fazia um montão de promessas
sem pé nem cabeça,
ou meu pai, que falava:
"Você vai sim, vai alcançar tudo isso".
No ano seguinte, estudei muito,
tinha que ganhar a camiseta.
E participei de todas as olimpíadas.
Na oitava série, ganhei oito medalhas.
E fui superconfiante.
Chegando na cerimônia,
adquiri um novo sonho:
eu vi que alunos brasileiros
podiam representar o Brasil
em competições internacionais de ciências.
Então foi o que eu decidi:
um dia eu vou representar o meu país
em uma competição internacional.
Estudei bastante
e, no segundo ano, fui pra minha
primeira competição, na China.
Foi a primeira vez que eu saí do Brasil.
E eu representei o nosso país
na Quarta Olimpíada Internacional
de Astronomia e Astrofísica.
Foi incrível!
Fiz amigos de todos os países
e realmente decidi que eu tinha
que estudar nos Estados Unidos,
pra ter essa experiência internacional.
No entanto, algumas coisas começaram
a ficar mais difíceis em casa.
Meu pai sempre teve muitos problemas
com vícios, e isso foi piorando.
E ele também desenvolveu
algumas doenças psicológicas.
Então, a situação financeira, que já não
era muito boa, começou a complicar.
E a gente não tinha mais
como pagar pela alimentação
ou pelo transporte pra ir pra escola.
E, aí, eu fui me afastando
de algumas atividades do colégio.
Mas, de novo, alguém acreditou em mim.
Dessa vez, não foi meu pai;
foi um professor, o professor Rubens.
Ele viu que eu estava
me afastando das atividades,
conversou com a diretoria
e, no dia seguinte, ficou decidido
entre os diretores
da minha escola e minha mãe
que eu iria morar num hotel.
Por mais que parecesse incrível,
eu moraria num hotel
a cinco minutos do colégio,
teria a minha alimentação
e o meu transporte pagos,
eu fiquei muito triste,
porque minha família estava passando
por um momento muito difícil.
Eu estava simplesmente
abandonando a minha família.
Mas, enfim... fui pro hotel.
E, pra aguentar firme,
decidi que faria duas coisas:
primeiro, me dedicaria ainda
mais aos meus estudos,
e, segundo, ao projeto VOA.
VOA significa Vontade
Olímpica de Aprender.
Antes do ensino médio, eu havia cofundado
esse projeto com alguns amigos.
E todos finais de semana preparamos
alunos de escolas públicas
pra olimpíada de ciências.
Eu acho que o VOA surgiu
de uma percepção muito grande
de que eu estava tendo
oportunidades incríveis,
mas que isso não era verdade
pra maioria dos brasileiros.
Então que eu tinha que fazer alguma coisa,
porque, se eu fui escolhida
pra ser tão abençoada,
tinha de fazer alguma coisa sobre isso.
Bem, continuei estudando bastante
e, no terceiro ano do ensino médio,
consegui representar o Brasil em outras
quatro olimpíadas internacionais.
Conheci a Polônia, conheci a Turquia
e multipliquei meu sonho de representar
o nosso país por cinco.
Foi uma época muito difícil,
e muito incrível também:
tinha que fazer o vestibular americano,
tinha que fazer o vestibular brasileiro,
tinham as olimpíadas...
e muitas vezes eu quis desistir.
Realmente dava muito medo de tudo isso.
Mas tinha uma coisa:
tinham muitas pessoas lutando
por aqueles sonhos comigo.
E já não era mais o sonho da Tabata
de ir para os Estados Unidos.
Era o sonho dos professores,
o sonho da minha família,
era o sonho dos meus amigos.
Então, continuei.
E, no ano seguinte,
fui aprovada em Física na USP.
Comecei a trabalhar como professora
de química e astronomia,
e comecei a cursar a faculdade.
E, no dia 8 de março de 2012,
recebi a melhor notícia da minha vida:
fui aceita na Universidade
de Harvard, com 100% de bolsa.
Eu não consigo nem expressar
como eu me senti feliz naquele dia.
Era a realização de um sonho
de mais de cinco anos.
Fiquei superfeliz
e liguei para os meus pais.
Eles tiveram duas reações
que me marcaram muito,
porque representa muito como eles eram.
Minha mãe atende o telefone e diz:
"Você já comeu? Você vai passar
mal, não? Meu Deus!",
superpreocupada comigo.
Meu pai, tranquilo do jeito dele:
"Olha, eu sempre disse que você ia passar.
Você deveria me escutar mais,
pra não ficar tão estressada".
Então aquele dia foi bem marcante pra mim.
Só que se passaram quatro dias
e, aí, eu recebi
a pior notícia da minha vida:
todos os vícios que haviam feito
meu pai sofrer por tanto tempo,
tinham matado ele.
E, aí, eu acho que quem já perdeu
alguém da família entende
que tudo deixa de fazer sentido:
a universidade americana, os meus sonhos,
os meus estudos... [inaudível]
E foi então que eu saí da faculdade,
porque minha mãe
tinha ficado desempregada,
então comecei a trabalhar mais,
e desisti daquela história
de ir para os Estados Unidos:
"O que é isso, sabe?
Não faz mais sentido".
E, bem, passou-se um tempo
e, num mês, eu tinha que dar a decisão
para as universidades - se eu iria ou não.
Eu estava decidida que não,
mas, outra vez, uma pessoa
importante na minha vida,
a Silvinha, que era da minha escola,
falou: "Você não vai fazer isso".
Comprou uma passagem pra ir
para os Estados Unidos às pressas e falou:
"Nesse final de semana,
você vai, e você vai entender
o tamanho da tua decisão.
E se, chegando lá, você falar
que não quer, tudo bem.
Mas você não vai desistir tão fácil não".
Fui às pressas visitar
as seis universidades.
No final, eu tinha sido aceita
em seis com bolsa completa.
Chegando lá, eu fiquei maravilhada.
Era tudo tão incrível, e as oportunidades
que eu teria tão maravilhosas,
como dizer não pra aquilo?
E aí eu percebi que, indo pra lá,
seria a minha maneira de mudar
a educação do meu país,
seria minha maneira de mudar
a vida da minha família.
Então, eu decidi que sim,
que eu iria para os Estados Unidos,
e ia escolher a Universidade de Harvard.
E, no dia primeiro de maio de 2012,
mandei a minha decisão.
Desde então, muitas coisas aconteceram.
Tenho estudado bastante,
trabalhei ainda mais.
Comecei estudando Astrofísica,
porque eu queria ser cientista,
depois mudei pra Ciências Políticas.
Astrofísica virou meu curso secundário.
Visitei e conheci muitos países.
Já fiz um montão de coisas.
E, nesse tempo, eu descobri
o meu sonho grande.
E o meu sonho grande
é que um dia o Brasil tenha
a melhor educação pública do mundo.
E é isso mesmo: não é uma
das melhores não, é a melhor.
E, aí, eu tinha esse sonho grande.
Mas o que você faz com ele?
Conversando com um grande
mentor, o Daniel Vargas,
eu falei: "Olha, quero mudar
a educação do Brasil, mas...
o que que eu faço?"
E, aí, ele me deu duas dicas muito boas.
A primeira: que todo mundo que ele tinha
visto tendo um impacto muito bacana
não tinha esperado ter 40, 50 anos,
tinha começado muito cedo,
quando você acha
que não consegue fazer nada.
Então ele falou: "Você vai começar
antes de sair de Harvard".
A segunda coisa é que toda boa ideia
tinha um time ainda melhor por trás.
Então ele falou: "Mesmo que você
não saiba o que fará exatamente,
monta seu time que as ideias vão surgir".
E aí eu convidei dois grandes
amigos: a Lígia e o Renan,
e falei: "Ó, pessoal, a gente tem
que mudar a educação no Brasil,
vamos fazer alguma coisa".
E a gente falou: "Então, tudo bem.
Não somos especialistas da educação.
Vamos fazer uma pesquisa.
Vamos estudar e ver
o que a gente pode fazer,
como que a gente vai convencer
essa juventude toda a lutar pela educação
e entender a importância da educação".
Primeiro, fizemos uma pesquisa:
entrevistamos mais de 100 pessoas,
estudamos diversos documentos
por meses, pra gente entender
qual era o cenário da educação no Brasil
e o que deveria ser feito.
Bem, essa pesquisa ficou tão grande
que acabou virando um manifesto.
E, no ano passado, lançamos
o manifesto "O Mapa do Buraco",
apontando os principais problemas
da educação no Brasil,
e o que alguns lugares estavam fazendo
que estava dando certo.
Como era época de eleições,
lançamos o desafio "O Mapa do Buraco".
Nele, a gente convidava
candidatos do Brasil inteiro
a responderem através de um vídeo:
"Se você for eleito, o que fará
pela educação do Brasil?"
Esses candidatos mandaram os vídeos,
desafiando no final três outras pessoas
a fazerem o mesmo.
Também realizamos, em parceria
com a Avaaz Brasil e com a FGV,
o único debate que houve
entre a Dilma e o Aécio sobre educação.
A gente sabe que a educação
não decidiu as eleições,
e que cada vez está
mais abandonada em nosso país.
Então, a gente decidiu mudar de nome.
Em vez de ser o Mapa do Buraco,
viramos o Movimento Mapa Educação.
O objetivo ficou o mesmo: engajar
a sociedade civil, engajar o jovem,
para lutar por uma educação
de maior qualidade.
Hoje, o Movimento Mapa Educação,
ou o Mapa, tem três objetivos:
o primeiro é engajar e informar
as pessoas através das redes sociais.
Então, diariamente,
em nossa página no Facebook,
divulgamos notícias
sobre a educação, resumo de artigos,
pegamos leis que estão sendo votadas
em Brasília e que afetam a educação,
colocamos pro nosso público votar
na página do Facebook,
pra que realmente a pessoa entenda
que a nossa educação não está bem.
E é a única coisa que a gente
pode fazer com segurança
pra garantir um futuro melhor pro país.
O segundo objetivo era criar
uma rede de pessoas,
com ideias e projetos
pra mudar nossa educação,
que pudessem se conectar
entre si e com outras pessoas.
Lançamos o "Desafio Mapa Educação",
e recebemos 170 inscrições
de jovens do Brasil inteiro
que tinham ideias maravilhosas.
Selecionamos os 100 projetos
com maior impacto,
e, no dia 29 de agosto de 2015, teremos
a Primeira Conferência Mapa Educação,
reunindo esses 100 jovens do Brasil
inteiro com empresários, com o ministério
e com as fundações que realmente
fazem a educação acontecer.
Um dos objetivos mais importantes do Mapa,
e o terceiro, é escutar a voz do jovem,
e saber o que o jovem
pensa sobre a educação,
o que funciona, o que o motiva,
o que o desmotiva.
Por isso, estamos
com uma pesquisa on-line,
pra realmente escutar a voz do jovem
e poder amplificá-la.
Hoje, o Mapa conta
com mais de 40 coordenadores
e tem apoiadores
pelo Brasil e pelo mundo inteiro.
O nosso objetivo é o mesmo.
E eu acho que tudo o que eu aprendi
com o Mapa e com a minha trajetória
me mostraram que realmente
a educação é a arma mais poderosa
que você pode usar para mudar o mundo,
como dizia Nelson Mandela.
E lembram aquele dia que eu fui
pra segunda cerimônia dos medalhistas
com as minhas oito medalhas, toda feliz?
Lá, eu descobri que, naquele ano,
você não precisava de uma medalha
pra ganhar a camiseta,
ou seja, se eu não tivesse
feito as olimpíadas,
teria ganhado a camiseta igualmente.
E foi então que eu descobri que,
muitas vezes, o caminho que você trilha
é muito mais importante
do que aonde você chega.
E é por isso que eu realmente acredito
que a educação é o único caminho
pra que o Brasil se torne
o país que a gente quer.
Essa é a única maneira da gente
romper todas as desigualdades
que temos pelo Brasil afora,
pra que todo brasileiro, independentemente
de quem seja e de onde more,
tenha uma educação de qualidade.
Muito obrigada.
(Aplausos)